he did something so embarrassing so
Bobby was flew to Atlanta last oh I know
this what he started bragging about our
oh me and steve aoki you're friends now
and we like we've been texting blah blah
they ran into each other at the airport
yeah and what happened at the airport or
outside the hotel the hotel I'm sorry
could I tell the story and so he I mean
like the whole his whole message to me
like one after the other like yeah so
like daddy's got his digits like I said
Brian to me because you're you were a
huge Steve Aoki fan oh I went to like
one of his shows and I was in Barcelona
but then I was like yeah I saw he's a
fan I said I said to him oh I saw him
once when I was in Barcelona right and
so he texted me back he's like oh yeah
but like do you have his digits are you
going to breakfast with him tomorrow I'm
like thanks right know like brag about
this brand-new friendship he created
right and so I guess him he screamed
shotted a conversation Janice Evo Key
says it says hey dude so glad I ran into
you and Bobby goes hey man glad we're
friends he screenshotted that with the
intent to send it to me to show it
showed him me as proof that they're now
friends right instead he sent that
screenshot back to Steve oh okay follow
a question that's ridiculous how did you
what did you do like no bi or well I try
to write as I send it I realized I did
it and I try to like click back onto the
thing Brian could delete it delete it
like somehow like not how after between
that and the cloud
Bobby tries to beat the clock yeah but
did it was already sent shouldn't I
started kind of sweating in my face oh
damn and I just went hahahaha I go ha ha
and I told him the truth I meant to sent
that to my girlfriend sent it to you how
embarrassing and he said oh that's cool
dude he kind of laughed it off but then
it never I think we're done our
relationship I think he's thinking like
Oh Mike yeah
oh my god he's not safe yeah yeah we're
not going to Hakkasan we're not going to
haka song yeah that was really
embarrassed that's a baby yeah
[Music]